Le drapeau européen doit-il être sur toutes les mairies ?
Oui.
La France insoumise est-elle la particularité publique,
hein ?
Oui. Est-ce qu'il faut encourager la natalité en Europe ?
Non.
Est-ce que ces news et europeen sont d'extrême droite ?
Oui.
Est-ce qu'il y a trop d'immigrés qui arrivent en Europe ?
Non. Est-ce que le
nucléaire va nous permettre d'atteindre la
neutralité carbone ? Non.
Est-ce qu'il faut livrer des avions de combat
à l'Ukraine ? Oui.
Est-ce que l'Ukraine doit rentrer dans l'Union
européenne immédiatement ?
Non. Est-ce qu'il faut arrêter de prendre l'avion ?
Oui. Est-ce que l'écologie est de gauche ? Oui.
Est-ce que il faut arrêter de manger de la viande ?
Oui, euh.
Mais je pense pas qu'il faut y aller dans 1 par.
1 voie coercitive.
L'Union européenne
atteindra la
neutralité carbone en deux-mille-cinquante
comme elle le souhaite.
Non, pas dans les marqueurs dans lesquels nous sommes
aujourd'hui, nous sommes déjà en retard.
Il faut accueillir en priorité les réfugiés ukrainiens,
non, faut accueillir les réfugiés, euh,
les personnes en recherche d'asile.
Il faut interdire la chasse en Europe.
Moi j'suis pas pour l'interdiction de la chasse,
c'est que c'est 1 débat.
Par contre, pour 1 régulation, euh. Importante,
les écologistes vont gagner les élections
européennes de deux-mille-vingt-quatre, il le faut.